[MUSIC PLAYING]
SETH VARGO: Today
I'm going to talk
to you about DevOps versus SRE.
This is a hot and
contentious topic.
Which one's better?
Which one's worse?
Are they the same thing?
Are they different, competing
standards or friends?
For those of you that don't
know me, my name is Seth.
I work on the Developer
Relations team at Google.
I've been at Google about
a year and a half now.
Prior to that, I
worked at companies
like HashiCorp
and Chef Software,
which are kind of regarded as
leaders in the DevOps space,
similar to other tools like
Puppet or Ansible or Salt.
And I've been involved
in this DevOps
space for quite some time.
I've written popular tools.
I've contributed to
popular projects.
And I've watched this movement
kind of from the beginning,
really since about 2007, 2008.
And I'd like to share
my perspective today
on what I think DevOps is and
how it relates to SRE or site
reliability engineering.
So with that, let's go
ahead and get started.
In the beginning, there
were two groups of people.
On the left, we have developers.
Developers are
concerned with agility.
They want to build features,
build software, and ship it
as quickly as possible to get
it in the hands of customers
and users.
On the right hand side,
we have operators.
Operators are concerned
with stability.
It's not broken.
Please don't touch it.
And this wasn't just
a personality thing.
This was driven by the business.
As an operator, it was
your responsibility
to make sure that the
system never went down.
And when the system went down,
you got a phone call or a page
in the middle of the night.
And it was your
responsibility to fix it.
And if you didn't do
it in a timely manner,
you might be fired.
But then on the flip
side, the developers
have all of these roadmaps
and Agile and Jira tickets
that they have to complete.
And if they don't complete
them and they don't get them
into production, they're
not delivering value
to the business.
And the business is suffering.
And then they're at
risk of getting fired.
And these are two
competing ideas.
As we introduce new features
and new functionality
into a system, we also
introduce instability.
Every new line of code we
write has the potential
to have a bug, has the
potential to have a performance
regression.
So these are directly
competing ideas.
We have developers
who are trying
to move quickly and introduce
instability and operators who
are trying to slow things
down as much as possible
because it's not broken,
please don't touch it.
But here's where things get
a little bit interesting.
Developers were closer
to the business,
both physically
and metaphorically.
Developers often sat
in the same building
as the directors and the
vice presidents and the CEOs.
They were physically located
closer to the business decision
makers.
Operators, on the other hand,
were often in a data center.
Their desk might be hundreds
or thousands even miles away
from the corporate office.
They often felt disconnected.
They felt like their
ideas weren't being heard.
Educationally, these
two groups of people
often came from
different backgrounds.
Developers traditionally
had a software engineering
background, computer
science, information systems,
computer engineering, something
along those lines from a two
or four-year degree or more.
Operators tended to come more
from a practical background.
They might have, like,
an associates degree
or a practicum in something
like network engineering.
So there's a skills
gap on both sides.
Developers are really good
at algorithms and writing
software.
Operators are really good
at understanding network
topologies and failure
scenarios and how redundant
does a SATA drive actually
need to be in order
to have this many
nines of availability?
But because developers were
closer to the business,
oftentimes they would
just write their code.
And they would throw it over
the wall to the operators.
That animation was nice, right?
Yeah, I worked
really hard on that.
So these developers would
throw their code over
to the operators.
And they'd be like,
here's my PHP.
Please go run it for me.
Thanks, have a great day.
And these operators,
remember, they
don't have a
traditional background
in software engineering.
They may have never worked
with these languages before.
In addition to the
responsibilities
of keeping the network
up and running,
making sure hard
drives are not filling,
making sure that servers
are not faulting,
they now have to understand
bugs in the application,
because when that
application goes down,
they're not paging
the developer.
They're getting paged.
They're getting woken up
in the middle of the night
for a bug in the
application code.
But because
developers were closer
to the business, when
operators would complain,
no one would listen.
So the DevOps movement
really in its purest form
is about breaking down that
wall between developers
and operators.
I know, that was
another nice animation.
By breaking down the
barriers between developers
and operators and aligning
the incentives between them,
we can deliver software
better and faster and more
safely for our end users.
What are some ways that
we can do this, though?
Well, one of the easiest
ways that you can break down
the barriers between
developers and operators
is to put them in the
same physical room.
This has been shown
to work successfully
time and time again.
It's a time tested pattern.
Instead of having your operators
go sit in the data center
hundreds of miles away,
put them in the same room
as the developers.
Make them attend stand-ups.
Make the developers
listen to the operators.
And all of a
sudden, you'll start
to have these amazing
conversations where developers
will try to be--
they'll try to write some
algorithm or some distributed
systems problem.
And they'll have
this great thing.
And it works great in theory.
Then you have an operator
that steps in and says,
so that's great.
But you're telling me that
you need 40 gigs a second
for network traffic.
And our data center is
running Cat5e cable,
which is maxed at, like,
10 over short distances
and five in reality.
So that thing that you're trying
to do works great on paper
and works great on
your local laptop.
But it will never
work in production
unless we upgrade the
cabling in our data center.
And just that small
collaboration saves the company
millions or even billions of
dollars investing in a software
project that cannot
be successful
because the underlying
hardware won't support it.
And this is just
one example of how
putting developers and operators
physically in the same space
helps improve the
software delivery cycle.
If you look at the
DevOps manifesto,
there's kind of
five key categories
that DevOps is broken into.
The first is reducing
organizational silos.
And I've already talked
a little bit about this.
How do we reduce the silos
that exist between developers,
the people writing
code, and operators,
the people making sure
that code continues to run?
What we quickly found,
though, is that that
was just the biggest mountain.
After you reduce the
silos between developers
and operators, who knows what
the next giant mountain is?
Security, legal
review, marketing, PR.
All of a sudden,
those little things
become the new mountains.
And this is where the DevOps
movement in its purest
form-- if you're a DevOps
purist, you're like,
no, it's just developers
and operators.
But in order to actually
do this successfully,
you'll see that it has to
involve cross-functional teams.
The same way that we
want to involve operators
in the development
lifecycle, we also
want to involve
the security team,
because if we involve the
security team early, instead of
our security and privacy review
taking six months for someone
who has no idea what
our product does,
who has no understanding
of our core business goals,
we instead have
someone who's regularly
attending our stand-ups.
They're regularly contributing
code and reviewing code.
And then when it comes time
to actually do the review,
they may be able to complete
it in weeks instead of months,
ultimately delivering software
faster, but also safer,
because they're far less likely
to miss something, right?
Reviewing 100,000 lines
of code is much harder
to spot a bug than reviewing
1,000 lines of code
versus 100 versus one.
The second piece of
the DevOps manifesto
is that we have to
accept failure as normal.
If you recall earlier, I talked
about fire, being fired a lot.
Developers are worried
about being fired
if they don't ship features.
Operators are worried about
being fired if they don't
deliver 100% availability.
This is not OK.
This doesn't create
a culture in which
people, humans, can thrive.
We have to accept
failure as normal.
Any system that humans build
is inherently unreliable.
And in fact, I would
challenge anyone
to find a system in nature
that is 100% reliable.
Most systems fail
given large scale.
So given that anecdote
or that lemma,
we have to accept
failure as normal.
It has to be built into
the core of our business.
We can't just fire people every
time the system goes down.
Instead, we need to
plan for it in advance.
So as a concrete
example, let's say
we're doing a
database migration.
We're about to roll out
a database migration.
Before we do that,
let's plan for failure.
Let's accept that failure
is going to happen.
So before we actually roll
out that database migration,
we're going to plan a rollback.
We're going to write a script
that rolls back our deployment
and rolls back the
changes to the data model.
Well, why would we invest
that effort in advance?
It might just work.
And you're right.
It may totally work and
that was wasted effort.
But the problem is if it
fails, if that deployment
or that database
migration fails.
Now your phones are ringing.
Your pagers are going off.
Social media is blaring.
Your boss is yelling at you.
Your boss's boss
is yelling at you.
The site is down.
You're losing money.
And you're trying
to build a plan.
It's not the best
time to build a plan.
The best time to
build a plan is when
there's not a lot of pressure
and you can think clearly.
So by accepting
failure as normal,
we understand that bad
things are going to happen.
There's going to be bad deploys.
There's going to be bad
database migrations.
How do we recover from them?
We need to think about
that before we deploy them.
On a similar note, the next
piece of the DevOps movement
is this idea of
implementing gradual change.
If you work in a waterfall
software development
methodology, you may deploy
once a year, twice per year.
And the problem
is if you're doing
that, you're deploying hundreds
or millions of lines of code
at one time.
And the chance that there are
no bugs in those million lines
of code is effectively zero.
It is very, very small
that there are zero bugs
in a million lines of code.
I don't care how good of a
software engineer you are
or how rigorous
your discipline is.
There's going to be a bug.
So you deploy the software.
And some users
start complaining.
Well, now you only have to
search through a million lines
of code to find the bug.
It's not that long.
It might take another
year, versus deploying
small incremental changes.
If we deploy, say, 10 or
100 lines of code at a time,
if all of a sudden our
monitoring starts failing,
our users are yelling
at us on social media,
our boss is telling us
that something is broken,
or our internal users are
saying, hey, this is slow now,
we know exactly where
to look for the problem.
The smaller that
change, the easier it
is for us to identify the
problem and the faster
it is for us to fix that
bug or roll back the change.
Rolling back a
million lines of code
is a lot harder than
rolling back 10.
Now on the flip side--
and this is my
soapbox for a moment--
I don't like when people
measure DevOps success
in deploys per day.
I think deploys per day
is actually a bad metric
for success in this industry.
You'll see it a lot where people
are like, oh, we deploy 6,428
times per day.
And I'm like, great, I can
add a comma to some Java 6,486
times per day.
That's not very exciting to me.
But the frequency
at which you deploy
relative to your business
and relative to your industry
is a signal.
It does tell you how well you're
practicing these methodologies.
If once per week is
standard for your industry--
maybe you're in something
like fintech or banking
where there's
regulatory requirements
and that's the industry
standard, that's fine.
You don't have to catch
up to some startup that's
deploying 100 times a day.
What's important is that you're
implementing gradual change
with respect to your
business and your industry.
End soapbox.
The next piece of
the DevOps movement
is this idea of leveraging
tooling and automation.
And this is where you'll
often see people confuse tools
like Chef, Puppet,
Ansible, Salt,
Terraform as DevOps tools.
And that's because those
tools largely guided
the DevOps movement.
They largely supported
that DevOps movement.
And they coincided with
the DevOps movement.
So a lot of people are
like, I'm a DevOps engineer.
And I'm like, what do you do?
And they're like, I
write Terraform configs.
I'm like, OK, maybe not
the appropriate job title.
That's fine.
But leverage tooling
and automation
is a key piece of
the DevOps movement.
What we found is that after
breaking down those barriers
and after accepting
failure as normal
and implementing gradual
change, it turns out
there's just a lot of
work, like creating users,
installing packages,
building Docker containers,
monitoring, logging, alerting.
All of those things take time.
And if you're a company
that has 100,000 VMs
and you need to roll
out an open SSL patch,
you can't have people sit at
a keyboard, SSH into them,
and run yum update.
It doesn't scale.
And we quickly learned this.
We quickly learned
that we have to have
tooling, we have to
have automation in order
to successfully
implement DevOps,
because otherwise you're just
constantly chasing your tail.
You're running around putting
out fires when instead we
need to be leveraging
automation and tooling
to make things repeatable and
to make a pattern out of these.
Another key point
is that humans are
inherently very bad at doing
the same thing over and over
and over again.
We get bored.
We get distracted--
oh, look, a butterfly--
whereas computers are really
good at doing the same thing
over and over and
over and over again.
So we should leverage computers
for doing the same thing
over and over and over again.
The last piece of
the DevOps movement
is that we have to
measure everything.
It doesn't matter if you
do all of these things.
If at the end of the day
your boss comes to you
and says how much more
successful is the business
and you say people
are happier, that's
not a business justification.
And I'm not saying
that we should
be justifying everything we do
with money or deploys per day.
But we have to have
numbers to support
the efforts that we're driving.
If today you don't
have any metrics
and you implement
all of these DevOps
things and everyone
feels better and you
know that the
business is better,
but when your manager
comes to you and says, hey,
we've invested $2 million
over the course of a year.
We hired a bunch of people.
We bought these
software packages.
We invested in this tooling.
What do you have to show for it?
And you don't have a tangible
metric to be able to point to,
it's unlikely that the
effort will continue.
And on the flip side, if you
don't measure everything,
how will you know if
you're actually successful?
You have to set clear
metrics for success.
And that includes at the
organizational level,
but also at the
application level.
Now, there's also a difference
between measuring everything,
monitoring everything, and
alerting on everything.
These are very different things.
You may measure CPU usage,
memory usage, available disc
space.
You may monitor
available disc space.
But you may only alert if
no one can use your checkout
page, because if a disc
is full, that sucks.
But hopefully you're running
in high availability mode.
And some other
service can take over.
And a human can clean that out
during normal business hours.
All too often I see
people adopting DevOps.
And they jump right in.
And they start alerting
on every metric.
And they don't understand
why their phone
battery keeps dying.
CPU usage is at 30%.
Oh my god!
30%.
Why?
We need to measure
and alert on things
that matter to our users.
Is the checkout page working?
Can people actually buy things
from our e-commerce site?
Can our internal users run their
analytics and their reports?
That's what matters.
That's what we alert on.
Then we measure the other things
so that when we get that alert,
we can find the root
cause or the root
causes that
triggered that alert.
So what you'll notice
here is that these are all
abstract ideas, though.
I know this is shocking.
You had no idea this
slide was coming.
These are all abstract ideas.
I gave you some examples of
how you might, say, reduce
organizational silos--
put people in the same room.
I gave you some examples
of measuring versus
monitoring versus alerting.
But they're abstract
ideas, right?
The way your company might
accept failure as normal
is very different than the
way another company might
accept failure as normal.
And what we found is
that a lot of companies
don't like abstract ideas.
They want more concrete
implementations.
So story time.
Independently of DevOps,
around the same time,
though, Google started
this discipline
called SRE, which stand for
Site Reliability Engineering.
It was an engineering-based
discipline--
so kind of on the
engineering ladder,
the engineering pay
scale, if you will--
of people who build and
maintain reliable systems.
Their job was to
keep, at the time,
things like search and ads up
and running all of the time,
or as much of the
time as possible.
So SRE is kind of like a very
prescriptive way to do DevOps.
And this is why
you might hear us
say this phrase every so
often, which is that class
SRE implements DevOps.
Let me explain what
I mean by that.
So SRE evolved
independently from DevOps.
Google was really in its own
little bubble at that time.
And they arrived
at SRE as the way
to build and maintain and run
production systems at scale.
And DevOps was kind of
built by the community.
And SRE was kind of built
by Google at the time.
Very recently, we've
learned that SRE should
be shared with the world.
For quite some
time, Google thought
that SRE was like our
secret sauce, if you will.
It was the thing that
differentiated us
from our competitors.
It was the thing that
differentiated us
from other cloud providers.
We shouldn't talk about it.
It's a secret.
We didn't even post
job postings for it.
But very quickly, we learned
that there's a language to SRE.
There's nomenclature.
There's ways to think
about production systems
that as a cloud provider,
when we go to a customer
and we start saying these
words and we start talking
about these concepts,
they have no idea what
we're talking about.
So we go to a customer
and we say, hey,
this service has three
nines of availability.
And you're depending
on it, which
means you can never have
more than three nines
of availability.
And our customers just look at
us like, nines, question mark,
like a German shepherd with
the head tilted sideways.
And this is when
we decided that SRE
doesn't have to be a secret.
It doesn't have to
be a secret sauce.
And in fact, other
companies can practice SRE.
And then Google stepped
outside of its bubble
and realized that
there's already
a practitioner-based community,
the DevOps community that
is trying to do this.
They're doing it
successfully in some cases,
unsuccessfully in other cases.
And that's because
it's not prescriptive.
DevOps is like an abstract class
or an interface in programming.
It says here are the
things you should do.
Go figure it out, whereas SRE
is a concrete implementation
of that class.
It says here's how you
reduce organizational silos.
Here's how you accept
failure as normal.
Here is how you
measure everything.
And this is why we say
class SRE implements DevOps.
Now just like in
programming, you
may have an abstract
class or an implementation
of an abstract class that
has other methods that
are not in the interface.
You may have additional
methods, additional functions
that aren't in the interface.
And SRE's the same way.
There are things in
the SRE discipline
that aren't really part
of the DevOps interface.
But SRE does satisfy
the DevOps interface.
And let me show you how.
So if we go back to
the previous slide
where we kind of talked about
the five key areas of DevOps,
how does SRE reduce
organizational silos?
Well, the first way
that we do this is we
share ownership with developers.
So SREs at Google share
ownership with the developers
by using the same
shared set of tooling
across the organization.
So there's a single set of tools
that both software engineers
and SREs use for
production systems.
And by leveraging the
same set of tools,
you have software
engineers contributing.
You have site reliability
And you start to build
high-performance, very reliable
tooling that helps people
get their job done.
On the other side
of the organization,
SRE has very prescriptive
ways for which we determine
the availability of a system.
And the way that
we do that results
in almost forced conversation
and forced collaboration
between product teams,
developers, site reliability
engineers, and even sales
and post-sales organizations.
How does SRE accept
failure as normal?
Well, one of the ways in which
we encourage that collaboration
I just talked about is
through these things
called SLOs, service
level objectives
which I'll talk about
more in detail in a bit.
But these service level
objectives-- in addition
to kind of forcing collaboration
between these different groups
in the organization, they also
force us to admit how reliable
or how unreliable
our system can be.
And by having that
conversation, we immediately
admit that our service
is going to have faults.
And as a developer
and as a product owner
and as a site
reliability engineer,
I can determine how
much fault I actually
want my product to have.
If I'm building a product that
is up against some competition,
it needs to hit the
market very quickly,
I may accept more risk so
that I can deploy faster,
I can deploy riskier
changes, et cetera.
If I'm building a product
that is targeting,
say, the health care space
or the aviation space,
that needs more nines
of availability.
That has to work
all of the time.
We can't have hours
and hours of downtime.
We have to have redundancy
and availability.
And that may slow down
our development velocity.
But this is a conversation
that occurs between the product
owners, the developers, and
the site reliability engineers.
Additionally, as
you might expect,
the SRE discipline
strongly encourages
blameless postmortems, which
are popular among the DevOps
community as well.
When an outage occurs,
it's nobody's fault.
And instead, we try to find
ways in which we can improve
the system moving forward.
Something that SRE does
that DevOps doesn't do
is we then generate metadata
about our postmortems
globally across the country--
or country-- company.
So for example,
at Google we know
that the vast
majority of our outage
comes from a bad
configuration change.
And that's a publicly
shared statistic.
And the reason we know
that is that in addition
to doing an isolated postmortem,
postmortem about an incident,
we then categorize and catalog
all of that information
into a database where we
can run reports and gain
statistics about what is
causing these overall outages.
And that can help you
build kind of meta-tooling
and better improve
the system overall.
SREs implement gradual
change by moving fast
to reduce the cost of failure.
Again, small
iterative deployments
are strongly encouraged
over large 100,000,
multi 100,000 line changes.
Tooling and automation is really
a key piece of the SRE culture.
In fact, SREs have this
thing called toil--
T-O-I-L. I'll talk about
it more in a little bit.
But toil is this
idea that you should
be spending on times that bring
long-term value to the system.
So you should be
investing your time
and investing your resources
in things that bring value
to the system in the long run.
SSHing into a system
and restarting a service
doesn't bring long-term value.
It brings immediate-term value.
But that's something that we
should fix in the long term.
So SREs invest heavily
in tooling and automation
in order to automate
this year's job away.
That's kind of an
unofficial tagline
among a lot of SREs at Google
is that the manual tasks
that I did this year I shouldn't
have to do again next year.
I should automate those away.
And lastly, we
measure everything.
We measure systems
level metrics.
But we also measure things
like toil, reliability.
And we'll talk more about
reliability in a bit.
But hopefully this is
clear as to why we say
class SRE implements DevOps.
SRE is a very prescriptive,
very concrete way
to satisfy the DevOps interface.
So given that, let's jump into
a few key areas that I think
are important to discuss.
The first is SLIs,
SLOs, and SLAs, oh my.
An SLI is a service
level indicator,
something like request
latency or requests per second
or failures per request.
They're a point in time
or an aggregate point
in time of a particular
metric about a system.
Basically an SLI tells you
at any given moment yes or no
for a metric in a system.
Is it healthy or is it not?
And you define that.
So for your system,
healthy may be
that the ratio of successful
requests to failed requests
is less than 1%.
So 99% of your requests
are successful.
So at any point in time, if
you imagine a point in time,
that's a binary
operation, yes or no.
At this moment in time, are
we up or down per that metric?
Then an SLO is a binding target
for a collection of those SLIs.
So while an SLI is
like a point in time,
if you imagine from
calculus, if you
were to integrate all of those
points over a time period,
like a quarter or
a half or a year,
that's where you
get your SLO from.
So the SLI measures up or down.
And then the SLO says
how much up or down can
we have in a particular
time period--
again, like a quarter or a half.
Then there's the one
that you probably heard
of before, which is an SLA.
An SLA is a service
level agreement.
This is a business
agreement that
happens between a customer
or a consumer and a service
provider.
The SLA is typically
based on the SLO.
Ideally, you want to break
your own internal SLO
before you break an external
SLA, because violating
an SLA typically means
you have to give money
or credits or
reparations in exchange
for violating that SLA.
So SLIs drive the
SLOs, because remember
the SLO is basically an
integral of the SLIs over time.
And then those SLOs
inform those SLAs.
But to give you a
better understanding
of who is involved
in this process,
I built this handy slide.
So product, SRE, and
software engineering
work together to build
those SLIs up or down.
Then the SREs and the
product work directly
to determine what that looks
like over a period of time.
And again, this is a function
of how fast do we want to move,
what are we up against in
the market, how much risk
are we willing to accept,
what's our target market.
And then SLAs are
generally built
by the sales teams
and the customers
maybe with some
negotiations from product.
But they have to be tighter
or less than the SLO,
because again, you want your
SLO to break before your SLA
breaks.
And sometimes SLAs are also used
as part of a sales engagement
where you can buy
more availability.
So that's not really part
of the SRE conversation
other than the SLO informs
kind of the minimum baseline
for the SLA.
So I often get this
question, which is like, OK,
so you have this SLI thing
and then this SLO thing.
And then what happens
when you go over?
You're like, OK, system
needs to be 99.99% reliable.
That gives me, like,
12 and 1/2 minutes
of downtime per quarter.
What happens when I'm out?
Like, can I just keep pushing?
Do I fire my developers?
Like, what happens next?
Well, this is where
error budgets come in.
So one of the things
that's important to note
is that it is nearly
impossible to find
a system that is 100% reliable.
And it is often cost
prohibitive to build
a system that is 100%
reliable, especially when
you're relying on
third party components.
Take, for example, this
two-dimensional material phone
on the screen.
This screen, or this
phone has 99% reliability
with its cellular
network carrier.
This is actually pretty
standard in most countries.
That's your SLA with your
mobile carrier provider.
So your mobile
provider is saying
that we will service
99% of your requests.
So 1% of your
requests will fail.
So let's say you have
some back-end service.
And you have an unlimited
amount of money.
And you say, we want
100% availability.
So in order to do
that, you would
have to run your own fiber
connections with redundancy
to every cell phone tower in
the country of your choosing
in order to be able to deliver
maybe 100% availability.
And then you'd need your own
kind of internet backbone
to run that.
And you would need on-call
people pretty much constantly.
Even if you did all of
that and invested millions,
if not billions of
dollars, the user
would only experience your
app at 99% availability,
because they are governed by
the least reliable components
of their system.
So even if you have 100%
connectivity between your data
centers and the cellular
network towers, that user,
that end user will only
experience 99% availability,
because they are governed by
the least reliable component
in the system.
And this is a key point
is that optimizing
for 100% availability
isn't just difficult.
Oftentimes it's irresponsible.
It is not in your
company's best interest
to optimize for
100% availability.
Instead, you should be
accepting failure as normal
and understanding
how much failure
is available for your system.
So like I said, that user only
experiences 99% availability.
So how do you determine how much
risk your service can tolerate?
How do I know how risky
my service can be?
Well, there are many
factors to consider,
like fault tolerance,
availability, competition
in the market, how fast
you're trying to deliver,
whether there's a giant
conference that you
need to launch at.
That was a joke.
But your acceptable
risk dictates your SLO.
So if you have a product that
has really critical market
timing and you know that
you need to deliver features
quickly, you may
say, hey, we're only
going to offer one
nine, 90% availability,
because we need to be
able to move quickly.
And we don't want to have to
focus on reliability right now.
We want to focus on shipping
new product and new features.
But again, if you're in a
different industry like health
care or aviation
where reliability
is super important, you
may say, like, hey look,
we only want to focus on
reliability right now.
We need to improve our
nines of availability
so that our customers
can trust us.
So as long as your
SLOs are met, you
can continue pushing new
features and new product.
But what happens if
you violate that SLO?
What happens if you've
exceeded your error budget,
which is the amount of failure
you can have within your SLO?
Well then everyone just
plays ping pong, right?
That's how this works?
No.
You can continue deploying.
Your developers can
continue building features.
But everything has to
focus on reliability.
They can't ship new
features until we
improve the reliability.
So the development
efforts, the focus
shifts from building
new features
and delivering new features
to improving reliability
and improving the
availability of the system
until the budget is replenished.
So just like a
bank account where
you get a paycheck
and the money goes in
and then you buy
some Pokemon cards
and then the money goes out
and then you get more money,
the error budget
works the same way.
It's that after we've exhausted
our bank account of error,
we can only focus
on reliability.
We can only deploy features that
focus on reliability or bugs
that improve reliability.
So what does that
actually look like?
Well, here's kind of
a pretty dumb version
of an internal graph.
So on the top, we
have the health
of the system,
which is measuring
the number of requests that
are under 300 milliseconds
at any point in time.
So this is like an SLI.
In the middle in the green,
we have the compliance,
the up or down.
Are the sum of the
requests under 300 seconds?
So you'll notice that that's
more of a step function,
because it's binary.
It's yes or no.
You're either above
or below the line.
And then at the
very bottom, we have
the budget of non-compliant
requests in our SLO budget.
So how many requests
are remaining?
What you'll notice there is
pretty far in the right hand
side, there's a drastic
increase in our latency.
So you'll notice the--
it's a little bit confusing,
because the chart goes down,
which is a decrease in
the number of requests
under 300 milliseconds,
which is an increase
in the number of requests
over 300 milliseconds.
So we see a drastic
increase in latency
that obviously
causes our compliance
to drop significantly.
And then you can
start to see that just
like my bank
account, all of that
starts to drop in our budget.
We start to see a massive drop,
because we have a prolonged
violation of our SLO.
And it's a steady decline
until we're back in compliance.
And then we gradually gain a
little bit more error budget,
because time is moving on.
And then we start
declining again,
because we have a regression.
And these types of charts help
inform how much availability
your system actually has.
And when we're at the
bottom of that budget,
we have to focus on reliability.
So you might ask yourself, well,
what just prevents developers
from saying, well, like,
I know I'm at the budget.
But this is an
important feature.
Why can't I deploy it?
Well, they can.
But they might lose
their SRE support.
So remember that
SRE is a discipline.
It's a separate organization
that partners with the software
and product teams.
And if the product team
and the software team
are not willing to be adequate
partners, the SREs will gladly
hand you the pager and
walk away, at which point
now developers are not only
responsible for building
new features, they're also
responsible for the reliability
of the system.
And I guarantee
you they'll start
improving the reliability of the
system that night at 2:00 AM.
Another thing I
want to talk about,
because I get a lot of
questions about it, is toil.
It's a fun word, toil.
It's like foil,
but with a T. Toil
is best described
as what it's not.
It's one of those weird things.
Toil is not email.
It's not expense reports.
It's not meetings.
It's not traveling.
These are all things we
call overhead, things
that are required to
do your job that pretty
much everyone in
the organization
needs to accomplish.
Toil is actually something
that is manual, repetitive.
Most importantly, it's
devoid of long-term value.
It's often incredibly tactical
and highly automatable.
Classic example of toil is
like SSHing into a system
and restarting a service
because it's out of memory
or it's spiking CPU
usage or something crazy.
That's incredibly tactical.
Right now, doing that,
graphs go back down.
Everyone's happy.
But it is devoid
of long-term value,
because that service is likely
going to out of memory again.
And you're going to
have to do it again.
And it's going to be repetitive.
And it's manual.
But it is very easy to automate.
That's a classic example of
something that's very toily.
And in the SRE discipline,
we measure toil
and we talk about
toil because it's
a very negative
consequence of the job.
If you're constantly
working with toil,
this can lead to
career stagnation.
No one got promoted
for restarting servers.
How many people got
promoted because they
restarted a server once?
Right, exactly.
No one.
And at the same time, a little
bit of toil is also good.
So there's a careful
balance here.
And every year, we kind of send
out a survey to all of the SREs
at Google.
And most SREs aim somewhere
between 10% to 20%
of toil in their job.
So you might ask yourself,
where's toil good?
It sounds like this is terrible.
I should automate everything.
Well, if once per
year you have to do
some very complex operation,
like some aggregate report
that spans multiple systems
and it's very complex
and it would take you
20 hours to automate it,
but it just takes you 15
minutes to do it manually
and you only need to
do it once per year,
it is not a good
return on investment
for you to spend
time automating that.
Instead, you should make sure
that other people on the team
know how to do it so that you're
not one person, documented,
et cetera.
But you shouldn't
waste more time
automating something than
it takes to do it over time.
It would take a hundred years
for you to reclaim that time.
No, it would take you 125
years to reclaim that time.
It's just not worth it.
Toil is also an excellent
way for newcomers,
like interns or people new to
the team, to learn the system.
There's no-- I mean,
there are better ways.
But one of the best ways to
learn a production system
is to explore it.
And being able to poke
around and understand
systems and understand how
they work with one another--
that's very toily.
But it's also a great
learning opportunity
for newcomers to the team.
Another value for toil is that--
how many people have
ever had a bad day?
Wow, that's like-- you are
all so positive people.
How many people have ever had a
straight six-hour meeting day?
I know that you've all had that.
Yeah, right?
And then at the
end of six hours,
you have 475 unread emails.
You basically feel like
you've accomplished
nothing for the day.
And then you get a page
that this server's out
of disk space.
And you can fix it.
Then you can go
home for the day.
And you feel like you've done
something with your life.
Toil can actually satisfy that.
Toil provides that
instant gratification,
but in small doses.
At a large, grand scale, we want
to eliminate toil as much as
possible.
We want SREs to be
focused on improving
the reliability of the
system and the availability
of the system, not
performing toily tasks
unless absolutely necessary.
So I've given you kind
of a brief overview.
You may ask yourself,
where can I learn more?
There's this happy link at
Google.com/SRE where you can
find all of this information
and a bunch more,
including two free books--
that's free e-books.
The first is the "Site
Reliability Engineering" book.
I like to call this the
theoretical calculus book.
And then there's the "Site
Reliability Workbook,"
which is like the
problem set, if you will.
They're both excellent books.
The SRE book talks
a little bit more
about the theory
and the history.
The workbook is a little
bit more practical,
a little bit more hands on.
And there's an entire section
about how DevOps and SRE relate
to one another.
Both of these are free.
Did I mention that they're free?
And you can download
them for free.
If you would like
a print version,
you can purchase them from
your favorite book vendor.
So to kind of conclude
here, is SRE DevOps 2.0?
No, it's not trying to be.
I also hate when people
put 2.0 on things.
Is SRE trying to
overtake DevOps?
No, lol.
And I learned yesterday
that I'm the only person who
pronounces lol.
I thought people
pronounced it, lol.
Can I adopt both DevOps and SRE?
Yes.
As I said before, if
you implement DevOps,
if you follow the SRE
workbook and SRE book,
you will be satisfying
the DevOps interface.
On the flip side, if you
satisfy the DevOps interface,
you might not be doing SRE.
There are a number
of other disciplines,
like VictorOps has a
thing called ProdOps.
There are other disciplines that
satisfy the DevOps interface,
but are not SRE.
Is DevOps dead?
I get this question a lot.
No one really talks
about DevOps anymore.
I think that's
because it's not dead.
It's just assumed now.
It's assumed that
you're following some
or all of these principles.
Is my talk over?
Yes.
We have about five
minutes for questions.
There are two microphones
in the middle of the room.
If anyone has questions,
please line up
at the microphone
for the recording.
While folks are
lining up, if you
have a question that you
don't feel comfortable
asking on the microphone
or on the recording, that
is my Twitter handle.
Feel free to tweet
at me at any time.
My direct messages
are also open.
So if you have a
question that you
want to ask that you don't feel
comfortable asking in public,
feel free to send
me a direct message.
I will get back to you
as soon as possible.
Thank you all so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]